this is Guam a tiny US territory in the
middle of the Pacific if War breaks out
between China and America this small
tourist island is where it could all
begin and yet it's surprisingly
vulnerable why Guam is the westernmost
part of America it houses military bases
for its Pacific Force as tensions over
Taiwan worsen and China increasingly
asserts itself in the South China Sea US
military leaders fear Guam could be a
target for early missile strikes such an
attack would hinder America's ability to
respond to an invasion of Taiwan Guam's
location is crucial it's close enough to
China to use as a springboard for us
bombers and other weapons yet distant
enough to be out of range of many of
China's missiles but in the past decade
China's military capabilities have
increased rapidly its df-26 ballistic
missile with a range of 4,000 km is
commonly called the Guam killer in China
and in 2020 a Chinese propaganda video
depicted an h6k bomber attacking an
undisclosed Air Base the satellite image
was unmistakably of
Guam despite its military value Guam is
only thinly defended its Thad missile
defense battery is not always switched
on and was intended to deter a limited
attack from North Korea not an onslaught
from China America is now investing in
beefing up the Island's air defenses
it's also tightening relationships with
allies like Japan and Papa New Guinea
but American intelligence Chiefs say
China's leader cin ping has ordered his
army to develop the capacity to invade
Taiwan by 2027 whether such an invasion
comes to pass could depend on how
quickly americ of fortifies positions
like Guam and how strong a deterrence
China considers them to
be